Speaker 1: I want to revisit with you.
Taxation is theft.
It's the little brother to taxation is slavery
that we sometimes hear from Republicans and
right wingers.
New congresswoman, a Republican, of course,
and Paulina Luna pulled out.
Taxation is theft yesterday when being interviewed
on Fox Business by Neil CAVUTO.
Let's listen and then discuss the endless
bottomless absurdity of this silly claim that
some Republicans like to make.
Speaker 2: I'm not going to say that I want
to cut defense spending, but I will say that
I think it's important that we are looking
to make sure that we are getting the best
deal, especially on some of the stuff that
we're spending money on.
So I think that we need to have those discussions.
But more or less, what I've heard in some
of these negotiations is we're talking about
programs that aren't going to the necessities
that we, the American people, need, i.e.,
protections.
I'm talking about some of these woke ideology,
these funded programs, and for example, these
these salaries for these additional weaponized
87,000 IRS agents, which you saw, we tried
to pass yet the Senate and even the Biden
White House is pushing back on.
Sir, I say taxation is theft and I don't want
any more IRS agents than you probably do.
Speaker 1: So, wait, I'm going to restrict
this segment to taxation is theft because
it's interesting.
Okay.
So first of all, Anna, Paulina Luna salary
is paid by taxes.
So if you really believe taxation is theft,
then you should be refusing your salary.
You should reject such an ill gotten and stolen
salary if you actually believe that taxes
are theft because you're being paid with stolen
money, sort of makes you an accessory to the
theft.
That's number one.
She's not rejecting her salary that I'm aware
of.
But let's talk about taxation is theft.
Taxation is theft.
Every once in a while rears its ugly head,
usually among libertarian circles, but sometimes
among reactionary MAGA as well.
Taxation is not theft in a number of different
ways.
First of all, nobody is forcing you to pay
taxes in the sense that you have the option
to work or not to work.
Don't want to pay taxes, don't work.
Oh, but then how would I fund my life?
Well, you have a choice.
Secondly, if you believe that the taxation
system in the United States is theft, you
can try to go to a different country that
might have a different system.
What you might find is that the countries
in which you can get away with paying no taxes
aren't places you probably want to live.
Now, you might say, Well, David, every every
country has taxes, so.
Well, if your argument is the American government
is stealing through taxes, you're free to
try to go somewhere else if the immigration
law will allow you and if the tax law is more
favorable to you.
Number three, you have decided to be here
in the sense that you either immigrated here
knowing that there are taxes in the United
States or your parents immigrated here and
then birthed you or your parents were born
here and chose not to leave and birthed you
here into this system where there is taxes.
So you do have recourse.
Your parents had recourse.
There are options here.
And then number four, you can also lobby to
get elected officials who agree that taxation
is theft.
And if they get elected, they can try to eliminate
taxes.
So it's not theft and it's not slavery.
Now, the bigger picture, of course, is there
is no way to have a civilized society without
taxes.
Anthropological research and other sociological
research tells us that what usually they talk
about 150, it's called the Dunbar number.
When you get to 150 people organizing 150
people, you need some centralization and some
decisions that are made thinking of the group
as a collective.
If you don't, you have untenable situations
that would prevent Homo sapiens from ever
advancing to the point at which we are now.
Ideas of every road can be private.
And you know, you build a road and then you
just charge people to go on it.
And every road is private or police is private
and fire is private.
These things, these things quite literally
do not work.
Once you get beyond groups of 150 people.
And so these folks are living in a complete
and total fantasy world.
Usually you don't hear straight up taxation
is theft from elected officials in the House
of Representatives.
You hear it more from activists, you hear
it more from anti-tax groups or libertarian
groups.
But to straight up here, taxation is theft
from someone in a position of power like this
really shows us the degree of radicalization
in the current Republican Congress.
And it is very, very scary.
One of our sponsors today is fume.
Fume is on a mission to accelerate humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that consume far
too many of us, including ones that harm our
health.
Fume is a natural diffusive device that uses
plants and behavioral science to trade out
your negative habit for a positive one.
Fume is not a vape, it's a non electronic
device designed to transform your negative
habits instead of pods filled with potentially
harmful chemicals like a vape fume uses cause
infused with plants like peppermint and cinnamon
for delicious natural flavors.
Fumes.
New version to model is snappy and tactile
with an adjustable airflow dial and a magnetic
end cap that's fun to fidget with its fumes.
Goal to make switching easy or even enjoyable.
They have thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have successfully
switched when other solutions didn't work.
Head to try fume dot com and use the code
Pacman to get 10% off.
Today when you get the journey pack, which
comes with three unique flavors and the new
version to fume the link is down below.